pieds dans la gadoue trois wagons sous
les bras des tickets de bus dans un
décor très coloré
vous l'avez compris notre vannes
national aura forcément un lien avec le
rocambolesque feuilleton du tcsp tcsp à
qui la commune go way donc c'est montrer
tous les protagonistes qui sont dans le
dossier qui s'ouvre devant donc couette
confiance en moi pendant notre monde
finalement l'année plus ce moment là
tirer chaque sens donc voilà tous les
protagonistes réunis c'est pas ou
compensés et missy un tel non c'est pas
monsieur untel mais il allait aussi sur
l'autre nous notons qu'il a donnée soit
mono là au moins on voit bien l'acteur
des lunettes rondes
on voit bien monsieur doit lever et puis
lorsqu'on voit la grotesque burlesque
représentation de l'objet d'une chose
d'une personne laval a toujours été en
lien avec un événement les esclaves y
voyait un moyen de caricatures et leurs
maîtres
aujourd'hui encore cette représentation
accompagne un exutoire la symbolique du
détournement était au départ incarné par
de simples bois bois à l'éffigie de ceux
dont on voulait se moquer vaval
l'héritier élevé au rang de grand bois
bois est le métronome celui qui dicte
les règles du carnaval
dans ce temps espace qui est bien
codifiée avec des jours précis les jours
gras du samedi gras au mercredi des
cendres
mais justement ce vaval s'inscrit dans
ce code de jours il est présenté à la
population le dimanche gras on le
découvre et surtout il est achevé brûlé
donc le mercredi des cendres
on symbolise en tuant le vaval la fin du
carnaval mais qui renaîtra de ses
cendres
l'année d'après depuis l'origine du
carnaval va mal et celui qui rassemble
sur tous les continents toutes les
composantes de la fête ici
il lui a longtemps été reproché des
formes trop abstraite mais dimanche
c'est trois en phase avec son époque qui
va accompagner ces sujets mais est il
vraiment nécessaire de chercher à savoir
ce qu'il représente